I lived I it's about how he lived the
little lid his life mattered
Rolling Stone calls a critically
acclaimed movie the hate you give an
emotional powerhouse follows a
teenager's journey to find her voice
after she witnesses a white police
officer shoot her best friend the film
was adapted from author Angie Thomas's
debut novel of the same name the book is
entering its 100th week on the New York
Times bestseller list you go Angie
Thomas's highly anticipated follow-up
novel on the come-up is out today it
tells the story of sixteen-year-old Bree
an aspiring rapper who is trying to make
it to support her family 20th Century
Fox just announced it will be adapted
into a movie - Angie Thomas is an Eng
Thomas joins us first on CBS this
morning good morning to you best-selling
author lady person and soon to be movie
star
but before we get into the interview I
saw some great video on Instagram of you
could we roll that tape please Randy I
love this shot that's when you first saw
your book in print right yes yeah I know
what a feeling that must be to see your
words on the page you said you always
wanted to write a hip-hop story why well
you know for me growing up hip-hop was
how I saw myself I didn't see myself a
lot in books you know as a kid I love
books but as a teenager I hated it
because I rarely saw books about me you
know like Twilight was big when I was a
kid and I have nothing against Twilight
but when I was a teenager I was like my
mom would not let me date a 300 year old
vampire so the stories I saw myself in
so that for me I wanted to talk to those
kids who also see themselves in hip-hop
so often they're called reluctant
readers and there's no such thing as a
reluctant reader they're just kids we
haven't found the right book and you
said you're not trying to create rappers
you're trying to create speakers what do
you mean you know I don't want kids to
pick up on the come-up and think oh now
I have to go be a rapper that's what I'm
supposed to do there's nothing wrong
with that if that's what you want to do
but I hope that they walk away
understanding that they have a voice and
to use it even when people judge you for
how
you use it to speak up and speak out you
know especially young black kids so
often they're criticized for how they
say things as opposed to what they're
saying
and I want them to know that you're fine
just the way you are continue to speak
up and clearly stories like yours
resonate with so many people across the
country and they actually are profitable
to as we know a hundred weeks on the
bestsellers list huh what is your
message to publishers about putting
pressure on them to tell more of these
stories to pick up books like yours well
I hope that they recognize that not only
will black kids read but other kids will
read about black kids and then other
people will read about them as well
whereas kids are white white children
yeah there's a academic named dr.
routine Sims bishops and she says that
books are either mirrors windows or
sliding glass doors three are just as
important so I hope publishing
recognizes that can I just care about
your own voice which is that you were
rejected a hundred times for a previous
children's book which is just just
amazing for any writer who's out there
who's thinking about giving it up can
you talk a little bit about that yeah
that was a hard time you know it was
rejected 100 over 150 times it's funny
too because my agent was one of the
agents who rejected it and now she's
your agent yeah now he's wait you know I
always tell everyone it only takes one
yes I have writer friends who's been
rejected 500 times one yes can change
everything so one yes did it for me and
it was one yes through Twitter that did
it for me buddy I mean through Twitter
what do you mean um my literary agent at
the time his agency held a
question-and-answer session on Twitter
and I was working on the hate you give
and I simply asked if a topic like this
was appropriate for a young adult novel
and he responded and he was like yeah
I'd like to read that and I sent it to
him and he signed me so something good
it came from Twitter talk about Bri
who's the central character in this book
in your new book yes Bri is for me she's
so many black girls Bri has a voice and
she knows she has a voice but sometimes
she speaks without thinking sometimes
she's a little impulsive and her family
has found themself into a crisis all of
a sudden because her mom has
unexpectedly lost her job but also Bree
has these hip-hop aspirations and she
wants to make it and she makes a song
that goes viral for all the wrong
reasons and she finds herself in the
center of a controversy too big to
control but as her family situation gets
worse she finds herself desperate to
make it even if it becomes means
becoming the very thing people have made
her out to be and you she says in the
book norwich you know you can't have
brie without brilliant yes and that's
part of the rob they're part of the rap
but I like how you break down your
rapping process because you can you can
you give some insight into that the
words come in your head and you do what
with them you know I go to rhyming
dictionaries but you know the thing
about rapping about hip-hop that a lot
of people don't recognize is it takes
skill it takes skill to do that and I
wanted to give some insight into the
skill set you're not just rhyming random
words you want purpose with every single
word that appears and meaning behind it
and so every single word that she
chooses she has a reason for doing that
and she wants to connect it so that in a
way is its own narrative so in a lot of
ways
rap is narrative fiction and it was free
the best rap as we go to break okay
gotta go
just okay what's a taste all right no
fallacies are sped melodies causing
fatalities and do it casually damaging
records without bandaging of managing
managing my own label my own salary and
actually affectionately there's no emcee
that's as bad as me that doesn't make
you go buy her bow thank you